there's nothing I'm about to say that
you haven't heard from me you know I'm
like [ __ ] Aerosmith
like I'm gonna play the same [ __ ]
song you know exactly what's coming
you know exactly there's no [ __ ]
surprises tonight El Paso
there's no surprises it's very
consistent it is are you bringing value
to an audience that compels them to do
something that you want
the reason nobody's growing why am I not
growing because every post you put out
is selfish how many people here have
been following me for longer than let's
say three years raise your hand
thank you so so for the people that
raise their hands they have seen so many
different things that I've done whether
it's texting by the way if you haven't
texted me yet please do I love that [ __ ]
um texting or snap or Vine or podcast or
askgaryvee show or dailyvee or weekly V
or email or changing like like the the
sheer amount of
ideation and strategy shifts and action
I'm just iterating at scale and
what's interesting to me is
it's so clear to me that I'm just
searching
how to say the same 15 to 45 things in
as many different ways as possible with
the hope that today by the way this
keynote this keynote right you've
consumed four years of it two years of
it hundreds of hours of it and yet maybe
it is just us being in the same place
with that's why I want to do q a there's
nothing I'm about to say that you
haven't heard from me you know I'm like
[ __ ] Aerosmith
I'm gonna play the same [ __ ] song you
know exactly what's coming
you know exactly like there's no [ __ ]
surprises tonight El Paso
there's no surprises it's very
consistent it is are you bringing value
to an audience that compels them to do
something that you want
the reason nobody's growing why am I not
growing because every post you put out
is selfish
nobody gives a [ __ ] that you bought a
new [ __ ] outfit
like I was at the Super Bowl this
weekend
like 8 000 people like God I can't
[ __ ] grow is Instagram broken I'm
like no you're broken
you're gonna post six pictures during
this Super Bowl one with a Hall of Famer
one with a rapper one at a cool party
nobody gives a [ __ ]
the reason so many people are consuming
less is because you don't want the fomo
that you're not at the Super Bowl with
Lil yachty
like I don't understand how people don't
get this
we live in a deeply selfish state of
trying to flex in front of people which
brings that person absolutely no value
every single post I put out I'm like why
would somebody look at this
what is in it for you
why would you like this why is this good
for you
I'm going to fly private home tonight
you're not going to see that photo you
see none of those photos
people posting photos of them flying
private does dick for you
what are you trying to tell me that you
can afford a nice outfit like what what
are you doing
so this is one big game of
self-awareness self-confidence and
insecurity where do you have those three
things mapped do you even understand
what you're good at because I'm 44 and
being an entrepreneur sucks [ __ ] 20
years ago nobody wanted to be it if you
were it you were a loser the word barely
exists thank you
now it's cool as [ __ ]
now you're a [ __ ] great student
you're a great operator you were
destined to be a tremendous lawyer or
CEO but no you have to have the Uber of
[ __ ] towels
like everybody's got their own ideas
like you're gonna start the next Big
Brand right like this is what happens we
go through Cycles so are you self-aware
like do you actually understand what
makes you happy and what are you good at
and then you just have to start asking
yourself like
can you get out of the thing that almost
everyone's stuck in which is living
their life based on somebody else's
opinion whether that's the masses
because you because listen every one of
us had some level of adversity in our
childhood which led to a chip on our
shoulder whether you were given too much
and you want to like make pretend you
weren't put on third base that's a chip
or you were given so little
that you [ __ ] have to climb like
everyone's coming from that place and it
just becomes one humongous [ __ ] game
of high school and you're still 32 years
old 29 years old 44 years old 64 years
old acting like we're still [ __ ] in
high school trying to be cool in front
of the [ __ ] popular kids makes no
[ __ ] sense that it needs to stop
as long as America and most of the rest
of the world continues to put money on a
pedestal we will have deep unhappiness
as long as success is predicated on [ __ ]
you buy we're gonna [ __ ] lose
we just have to get out of this we have
to get out of it because
everyone's like so much more suicide
it's got to be social media it's not
it's the continuous consumerization and
having self-worth wrapped up in products
and opinions of other people
Instagram isn't leading to depression
you're depressed
like this like this cop-out that is the
current conversation like it's this
fault good news if you're [ __ ] sad
and insecure you can throw this out I
promise you you're still gonna be
satisfucking insecure as [ __ ]
to not make money is to go into an
industry that you think there's money in
but you have no interest or knowledge of
it
and I think people do that every day
people roll up Gary I'm gonna be in
social media I'm like where are you at
they're like well first I don't have it
yet but it's gonna be huge I'm like wait
you don't even use it no but you're
killing it I'm like cool that's like me
rolling up on LeBron and be like yo I'm
going to the Hall of Fame
New York that went in so I'm gonna
[ __ ] pick up a basketball and do it
it makes no sense
like
it makes no sense so I don't know just a
lot of swirling but most of it is the
reason you're not posting is you're
worried what people are gonna say and
you've decided in your own head who's
gonna listen to me and why would they
that is where I'm at I am really focused
on that this whole notion of people
saying no for themselves before they've
even started on some that's how you were
parented or that's the environment you
grew up in stuff is very very real to me
and something I'm trying to chip away at
which is have the humility
have the humility to figure out that let
the market decide if you're good or not
and more importantly
Don't Front
don't talk about [ __ ] you don't know
watching people try to talk about stuff
they don't know is wild
like it's so like right think about the
[ __ ] you actually know something about
and then you get into some conversation
or you see somebody post about it and
you know they don't know it's like a
weird feeling
you don't like them
right like you don't like them and and
I'm watching people trying to fake it
like fake it till you make it with some
1987 [ __ ] laughs it's a lot harder now
because while you're faking it's getting
documented and that's bad
right like like
the app bite came out from the people
that did Vine and people were rushing to
say it was going to be the next big
thing because they were guessing
with the hope that it would be so they
could show the video in three years
but the problem is what if it's not like
a lot of people it's really funny this
one guy
I love reading comments I get so much
information and you obviously get your
fair share of hate this one guy's like
okay garyvee like you keep showing these
videos from 10 years ago first of all
you look like [ __ ] cool
second of all
you know like cool that you're showing
this like why don't you show all the
videos of the stuff you got wrong
so I was like reply to him like bro it's
all there why don't you show me the
videos of what I got wrong
I'm not going to talk about bite the day
it comes out and predict it's going to
be the next platform as a matter of fact
everyone's like I actually started with
it I actually don't think I see around
corners or have intuition I think it
already happened and I'm willing to jump
in when it happened and most people are
scared to jump into something when it
first happened because most people are
built on fear I didn't put everyone's
like first of all I started talking
about Tick Tock 98 of the reactions are
complete cynicism how much Equity do you
own in Tick Tock zero dick zero
I'm playing for reputation out here not
[ __ ] a couple of shares to make some
money
zero and then everybody everyone's like
you're crazy this is stupid at the time
they only know their 11 year old nieces
on it
and then like everything that's ever
happened to me a year later everyone's
on it and then they're like man you're
so smart you're a genius I'm like I'm
not it already had a [ __ ] billion
users on it when I started talking about
it
I didn't predict tick tock
it was humongous
it was humongous when I started getting
serious about it Snapchat when I started
talking about it early too that was the
last thing that some of you might have
saw before this it was humongous I was
waiting I was waiting for DJ Khaled
Tick Tock I was waiting for Charlie I'm
waiting for the cultural moment that I
know can take it to the next spot
I was on Twitter for a year it wasn't
until Ashton Kutcher went on CNN and
challenged CNN to see who got to a
million first that that's when I knew
okay here we are there's always a moment
that's what I'm good at I may be good at
understanding the moment when
something's going to go to that next
place and honestly I've been able to do
that with human beings not just
platforms so yes fine that's a knack but
it's not confusing
my biggest question is if you're here
this evening which I'm very humbled and
grateful for
besides you know
coming because you appreciate me which
means a lot to me what means a lot more
to me is like what can I talk about
tonight that will actually get you to
start doing
this is only a game about doing
everything we talk about like I've given
you the black like people like you never
talk about Gary you just talk
motivational [ __ ] like you don't
give me some [ __ ] strategy some
details I'm like I do
I give the here's the single best piece
of advice I could ever give watch what I
do and do it
I do nothing by accident
there's nothing I'm doing for kicks and
giggles
nothing
like zero
I I want to do texting it's probably a
good idea for you to figure out how to
get a text number to do something with
I'm not doing it because it's fun
I'm not doing it because it's clever I'm
not guessing out here so you can make
fun of me for doing it in seven years
so the strategy is basic contextual
creative at scale
in places that are underpriced Tick Tock
and Linkedin are underpriced you need no
money zero
you start an account you make something
with your phone you post it
but Gary you have a huge team and
[ __ ] drock and all this but I didn't
for seven and a half years and I did all
by myself
you don't talk about that
like I just like help me figure out
which excuse you want to use because
I'll give you the answer but way more
importantly help me what you're scared
of
you're scared that somebody Anonymous is
gonna say you don't look good so it
takes you seven hours of makeup and
lighting to get a post up
because [ __ ] Ricky pants seven is
gonna say you're ugly
is that where we're at because I'm gonna
save you time that's where we're at
you know
[ __ ] you Ricky is right
and especially when Ricky is your mom
when Ricky's your mom that's when it's
really [ __ ] you time foreign
the biggest thing I learned by reading
these hundreds of thousands of messages
is
and it's continuously why I'm so
grateful is right
unfortunately like my father but
fortunately for me not like me
there's a lot of moms out there that
make people feel bad
I get it I I've lived in my whole life
I've watched my grandma my dad's
relationship I know what mine was which
was the opposite I understand how we're
completely different I'm I know why I'm
Fearless I'm not scared of anybody or
anything because I'm in my own head
that's where I live and that's it it's
also it's also why
when I get admiration or stopped or all
this I don't hear that either you're so
humble Gary it's because I know I don't
mean anything
you know what's the most amazing feeling
is when you think you're the best and
you know you mean nothing
that's why I'm so happy
it is I think I'm great I think I got a
lot in me I think I can leave some real
[ __ ] Legacy [ __ ] I'm looking for
November 14th to be a national holiday
when I die my birthday that's right I'm
looking for that [ __ ] that's where I'm
aiming like [ __ ] it
If Abraham Lincoln can have it [ __ ] it I
want it too
but I also know that God forbid if I'm
ghost tomorrow cool I'll probably get a
solid eight hours on social of some
serious love and then what we're living
through right now one of the great
iconic like
it's already getting quieter
show me how much we're talking about
Kobe in 60 days
life moves on
my flu's on that's just the world no
matter who you are that's how it goes
right when you think about the legacy of
all the people we admire over the last
decade right you get to the Oscars and
this stuff and they play remember you're
like oh [ __ ] right
right
so like that's the power like
what makes me what makes me roll my fuel
is humility
you see the bravado in the way I
communicate that's [ __ ] Jersey
I can't help that I'm from Jersey that's
Jersey that's where I get that from but
let that not confuse the words that are
coming out of my mouth this is about
humility
of course it's easy to navigate when
you're not worried about other people's
opinions of course
the biggest reason so many of you
struggle with negative feedback
is you over are excited when you get
positive feedback
that's the unlock my friends the unlock
is what's made you vulnerable
is the addiction to the positive
reinforcement you're so beautiful you're
so beautiful you're so beautiful you're
ugly that's devastating
you're so great you're so great you're
so great you make a bad decision in
business you go back a step you [ __ ]
are a loser we knew you were bullish you
got it it's that
it's really fun I'm telling you guys
help me come with me on this [ __ ]
Journey put your two [ __ ] index
fingers in your ear hear nothing from
nobody ever and [ __ ] live in
happiness forever
and let there be no confusion I do not
sit up here naive and and I do not
understand that that's not so easy if
your framework was always to get
affirmation
I'm just telling you the unlock whether
that's therapy whether that's running
whether that's yoga whether that's a
different diet whether that's cutting
out people in your life that are trying
to tear you down
and always will because misery loves
company is a thing for a [ __ ] reason
and so I don't know what you are or what
it is but I promise you this
the second
you surround yourself with optimism
instead of negativity good [ __ ] happens
and it's funny to watch cynical negative
people when I talk about this
Gary no no no I'm just keeping it real
I'm like real [ __ ] negative dick
you're keeping it real [ __ ] negative
I think the literally the most
disgusting
trait in a human being is cynicism
stating
if you look at every
every like what's gonna go wrong like
what are they up to how they gonna get
like it's a devastating way to live
I love when people let me down I don't
know if it was A Bronx Tale is that the
one where the [ __ ] mobster tells the
kid that kid doesn't right is that it
yeah bro that's the best [ __ ] scene
ever I live my life that way I love when
people [ __ ] let me down I'm like good
next
like like people are so insecure like oh
that person got me
he get you she get you they got
themselves
you're in control of never doing
anything with them again I I give Trust
I give trust from the second I meet you
I trust every single person in here on
some real [ __ ]
and then I watch for you to take it away
old school all the old school Russians
around me like you got to earn trust I'm
like why
don't you give it to them first and go
the other way everyone's on [ __ ]
defense
everyone's [ __ ] scared what you got
caught you got clowned
based on who
the person that does wrong [ __ ] is the
Clown
you're strong
you're strong when you give somebody
love and respect up front
how [ __ ] strong I am
there's nobody beating me out here on
emotional [ __ ]
I'm serious I'm giving you everything I
got everything what you
I I've watched people navigate it makes
me laugh I saw this kid interact with
another kid on Twitter making jokes that
he consumes all my content repackages it
and sells it for 99 ebooks and made a
million dollars in two years and he's
like I'm tricking Gary I'm like you're
not tricking [ __ ] dick
you're not tricking me it's not coming
out of my pocket
I'm like you've got to live with that
I'm not worried about that copy more
copy more I'm in your [ __ ] brain
I'm in your [ __ ] brain you can take
the million dollars I'll continue to
[ __ ] puppet you that's more
interesting
like like I don't understand what people
are thinking like my friends kindness is
strength
empathy is strength
gratitude is strength foreign
[Music]